yesterday i did a video and i told you
to start taking action
i said stop watching youtube videos
right now and just go out there start
viewing properties start making it
happen i've been overwhelmed with people
messaging me
um some people have been getting stuck
saying something like i'm stuck i need
some help or i've got a potential deal
what do you think of this deal
and i'm talking service accommodation
because service accommodation
i mean i'm in one right now you know you
rent a property on
a developer off of a landlord and then
you stick it on airbnb stick it on
booking.com
it really isn't that hard hey how you
doing
come on in thank you okay
this isn't my hotel factory one of my
students hotels
one of my students hotels um he doesn't
own it he controls it
see he went straight to a developer a
big deal and a small deal
i do the same amount of hardness like
this 12
12 apartments one of my students jesse
he went straight to the developer
he said can i rent this whole thing off
yeah
the developer said yes and negotiate the
price
he's renting this whole thing then he
stuck it on airbnb sticking on
booking.com
i was one of his guests yesterday a
small deal and a big deal
at just about the same amount of effort
so what i want you to do by june 21st
before the lockdown officially ends is i
want you
to get a small deal and then when you
get a small deal and you know how it
works
you begin to get a bit of cash flow 500
pound a thousand pound coming in
then start getting bigger deals and
scaling up now as you get a lot of
messages off people yesterday
asking me for help asking me to look at
deals asking me to review things
asking me should they where should they
start what area how does it work
how do guests let themselves in how do
you systemize it
how do you get the cleaners key safes
codes
automation like what's the crack so
here's what i thought i'd do
i'm going to give away 1 000 pounds
worth of training
to somebody okay and i'll see how that's
going to work in a second this is the
apartment by the way
absolutely beautiful gotta be high-end
gotta include everything
where do you get this stuff from you
know um
how do you stop guests coming and
trashing the place how do you stop
having bad guests
like this dude how do you stop having
people like him
what was if he trashed the place he
probably would if i wasn't here
in fact where did you where did you
sleep last night right right here on
this bed this isn't the bed but this is
a sofa
okay so you can it's a sofa bed mark my
bed where i slept is a zip bed
it looks like a double bed it's actually
not you can you can split it up and it's
a zip bed you can have it into two beds
um but anyway here's what i thought i
thought um i've created a training
program it's called the service
accommodation intensive it's a 1 000
training program online a six week
course
guess what's happening in six weeks
lockdown ends guess what i want you to
do before lockdown ends
i want you to get one deal i want you to
bag a deal so
i've opened up a competition here's how
this is gonna work i just did a post on
instagram
of me standing outside this hotel
okay so if you head down to my instagram
you'll see a photograph
of me a post standing outside this hotel
all you need to do go down to my
instagram
okay this is a giveaway right now this
is a give back friday
go down to my instagram like the post
tag
three friends that don't already follow
me and share the post
share it on your story okay take you
like 60 seconds
go do that and that shows me that you're
committed because if you can't even
do that if you're like oh that's too
much work then you're not going to have
to go get a deal
okay you're not going to be able to go
and secure a deal you're not going to be
able to
speak to the landlord so show me you're
committed because
before june 21st i want to play big i'm
getting some big deals
before june 21st should you come here
hop down to instagram like
tag three friends share the post on your
story and i'm gonna be choosing one
person
at random but i believe it with the
person who's meant to be
and i'll message you direct and i will
give you
full access to the service accommodation
intensive
where it's the full training program
there's no additional training that we
offer that's like the high-end package
uh the advanced the ultimate the
mounting top six week course
um where we where we take you through
exactly step by step how to do due
diligence how to choose your area
how to go get a deal okay so
head down to instagram go do those three
things
you'll see the picture of me on my
instagram and i can't wait to work with
you
but even if you don't get picked you
know to get the free training just start
taking some action man
to start doing some stuff and if you get
stuck message me on instagram i can't
wait to see you succeed i can't
wait to see you win i just want to see
as many people financially free
by june 21st so people don't have to you
have to go back to your job
you know you only need one or two deals
you don't even need to buy them you can
just rent them and then re-rent them
on booking.com airbnb with the
landlord's permission
and it replaces an income so
go do it go apply yourself into the
competition
i think i'm going to do a give back
every friday you know every friday i
should give something away or
because man i appreciate you by the way
i appreciate my subscribers and my
followers
so go do that go start taking names
kicking ass and i look forward to seeing
you guys tomorrow